do i know how many times the company
name has been mentioned in the rap song
i do not but i'm pretty sure it's a lot
um 121 times oh yeah
that's a lot of times
[Applause]
what's up gq i'm joe aviani and this is
on rocks
[Music]
a lot of our clients have been a lot of
celebrities they come from the
basketball world the football world the
entertainment world jamie foxx
tom cruise chris brown
lil wayne
and so on and so forth
[Music]
[Applause]
well let's talk change man
this was created for slick rick he
wanted to have the biggest chain on the
planet this is a cuban that weighs 12
pounds so putting this on
imagine having the big africa piece that
we did from that's in the guinness world
book of records along with this
particular chain that's pretty heavy you
got to be you know doing a workout
wearing this [ __ ] he's been talking to
me about this for years
it's one of his biggest dreams ever
to own a big cuban laying one of the
biggest cuban links
it's probably gonna run him about 400
000
you know i want to talk about koi
corey larae i met i'd say about four
years ago
her name is coy she's beautiful iconic
vibrant so why not make a koi fish
chain for her
because a koi fish chain is also
beautiful vibrant with many different
colors
this piece came out beautiful
when this dropped
this broke the airwaves and besides it's
breaking the airwaves it put a smile on
her face because nothing that she has is
what anyone else has so when she's in
the room she's going to be the focal
point of the room
the wassac necklace
this particular piece was made
for bobby schmurder
as you could see it's not a regular
necklace as you can see the way it's
sitting on my hand is not like a regular
chain would sit
when i thought about this i thought
about pharaohs and how they used to wear
their their chains and their jewelry in
that time thousands of years ago
bobby didn't hit me up to create this
piece this piece was already created and
i just had it hidden
and i was waiting for the right talent
to put it on
[Music]
the main main main person who gave us
that
that battery on the back
and let us know that we're able to do
anything as my man killer from diplomats
camron just got signed to the rock came
in here asked for a million dollars
worth of jewelry right there on the spot
can you imagine being
in your early 20s and you solidify a
deal
of that magnitude
what would you do
i asked them i said look man we're doing
your mona lisa the mayor mona lisa you
know i want to throw a chain on it
that's never been done
this particular chain right here
if i show you how this was concepted
you wouldn't even believe it
my wife and i were in a store in arizona
and i saw a chain there
that i liked in
i took this
and i put
this
from it
put the blueprint together pitched it to
cam
i mean and cam was like joe
you're the godfather of this [ __ ]
do your thing
we want you to be different cause
jewelry speaks volumes without you
having to say a word it's pac-man chain
right here just look at the details of
this
look at the two carrots each diamond
that's in here
look at the two-tone effect that's here
pac-man jones adam jones retired
football player he never did anything
generic always wanted you know his own
and why not come and share your concepts
with us whatever it is and we bring it
to life and that's what we created for
[Music]
ah you want to talk about this one right
here with the ak bullets for sniper gang
huh
this right here is made for kodak black
you guys remember that platform myspace
this kid was hitting our company up
since then so this particular chain was
made for him
you know as you can see they go to
target
you know that sniper gang target we had
we ended up putting the avioni a to
brandon
plus with these ak bullets in between
are
cuban links this is 120 000 ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
i want to welcome one of the co-founders
of runts one of the largest brands in
the world
in the cannabis business my brother lb
welcome to the show
good to see you brother man great to see
you man i wanted you on this particular
segment man it's because what we're
about to introduce of the world has
never been done before brother
everybody does like you know medallions
and all this and like cuban links were
like baguettes and just the biggest
piece in the world type but i was just
trying to come with something that was
like an innovation that ain't never been
done before so i asked all the jewelers
and they were just like nah it hasn't
been it hasn't been i'm like can we do
it like we don't know we could try so
from that when i pitched the idea
this man was one of the dudes that
literally made the idea come to life
it's the dna link you know
so we're rolling it out here on the
rocks first yeah this is something
different you know and especially and it
was one of a kind like it ain't never
been done in history like the link has
never been done
i don't think there's one person on
earth that ever came up with a dna link
i'm proud to say well you know my
partner with my brother we came through
and executed the project for all the way
let's talk about
watches ladies and gentlemen there's
nobody doing
art into watches what everyone is doing
is taking
the basic rolex
or the basic audemars psja or the patek
philippe and just doing what anybody
could do is just
bust them down ain't nobody doing this
type of work look at this this is for my
man cam
take a look at this watch this is still
in pieces it's still a prototype but
this is his iconic diplomat logo turned
into a timepiece
take a look at the star band
like who's doing this
take a look at the bandana that we're
doing for blueface just continue going
with his you know image his style and
his likeness take a look at this there's
no one doing something like this ladies
and gentlemen we're always pushing the
envelope you know the starting price
point would be about twenty thousand
take a look at this specific watch
that's created for bobby schmurder these
are just in production stages this isn't
even ready but
imagine this
being on someone's wrist
what are you thinking when you're seeing
this
some royal [ __ ] liberace how you doing
you know
people ask me every day what was going
through your mind when this came into
your head i said i don't know
it just happens i guess every artist has
their frequency that they're tuned into
and these concepts just keep coming to
me we're just
blessed to facilitate our ideas and
create them
we have our own watches that we've been
creating for the last 21 years as well
so this is what we decided to do this
last few years let's just create art
pieces bring art
to the watch game which no one is doing
take a look at this magnificent feast
right here look at that
a man lb
if you have something like this on your
wrist it's already doing a lot of
talking
like who's doing this
put the skeleton on there
no one's doing that
this specific ring right here was
created about eight years ago
when it was first made
and put on display young thug walks in
here young thunk was like oh my god let
me get the chain let me get the
medallion and let me get the ring
take a look at the boogers that's in
this particular ring this ain't your
average little chips that's in there
ladies and gentlemen these right here is
boogers
see how big they are rocks
you know ring like this is about 40 000
on my pinky
let's talk about this particular one
right here
my man two changes ring
like look at that who's doing that look
at the craftsmanship look at the
different color stones look at the
different shape stones look at the metal
the ring is yellow gold with the white
border going around it
all these small details
add to the brand value because we pay
attention to all these little details
i mean
look at that
takes up my whole finger
this ring right here is 50 000.
that's the number one question there's a
few million dollars here ladies and
gentlemen how you doing
a little below 10 mil i would say just a
little below 10 mil